Batman is finally living up to the
"detective" part of "detective comics."
In the new movie "The Batman," directed by Matt
Reeves and starring Robert Pattinson as the
"Caped Crusader," fans of the classic DC character
are introduced to a new version of Bruce Wayne.
The film opens with a brutal murder,
revealing that there is a new serial
killer on the rampage in Gotham City, aiming
to expose the lies of corrupt public officials.
Meanwhile, a thriving illegal business circulating
drugs called "Drops" is run by Carmine Falcone and
Oswald Cobblepot, a.k.a. the Penguin, and
Bruce is caught in the middle of it all,
trying to help save his city and the people in it.
A lot of the characters in the movie are very
familiar to fans, including Selina
Kyle, a.k.a. Catwoman, James Gordon,
and Alfred Pennyworth. But there
are also some striking changes in
"The Batman" compared to other screen
adaptations of the superhero's story.
In this case, the biggest change comes in the
form of Batman's goals and everyday behavior.
In "The Batman," Bruce truly takes on the role
of detective, looking closely at all of the clues
laid out by the Riddler in order to catch him.
"You came; I've been trying to reach you."
In "The Batman," the defining difference between
this version of Bruce Wayne and any other we've
seen on the big screen is that Pattinson's
Batman is more detective-like than ever before.
Although he's still a vigilante who uses
technology and his fists to beat up the expected
criminals on the street, he also understands that
careful observation and investigation can get him
far, especially when it comes to the Riddler.
The Riddler is the main antagonist of the film,
and he is introduced through the murder of Mayor
Don Mitchell Jr. Bruce shows up alongside the
police officers and detectives of Gotham City
to the crime scene, called there by Gordon.
While one main reason Gordon calls him there
is likely the letter addressed "to the Batman"
left by the body, it's probably also due to
Bruce's talent in taking notice of the details
and tracking down criminals. For example, Bruce
quickly takes note of a key piece of evidence
nearby: the blood spatter on the ground from the
carpeting tool Riddler uses as the murder weapon.
At this point, it looks like the investigative
team hasn't even spotted it yet themselves,
as a crime scene photographer notes his actions
and photographs the blood after Bruce moves away.
Bruce brings Gordon along early on to the mayor's
car, where he finds the USB drive that the Riddler
left containing evidence of his shady dealings at
the club. He also finds the note in the Riddler's
apartment hidden in the bat cage all on his own.
Overall, Bruce clearly understands the value of
intelligence and patience, particularly
getting into the detective mindset as
he tracks down the Riddler, who challenges
him through the constant riddles as clues.
Seriously, Bruce is surprisingly skilled
at riddles, showcasing Reeves' decision
to emphasize Bruce's mental strength
alongside his physical capabilities.
"Justice. The answer's 'justice.'"
Although Bruce spends a lot of "The
Batman" fighting criminals on the street, he is
actively investigating the crimes of the Riddler,
Cobblepot, Falcone, and the corrupt
officials Riddler brings to light.
In this investigation, Gordon is arguably his
right hand man, and the police detective clearly
respects Bruce's abilities and drive for justice.
At one point in the film, he even says that Bruce
is the only one he trusts, representing
his unwavering loyalty to the vigilante
whose real identity he doesn't even know.
The two connect through the bat signal
when Bruce needs to go out and fight
criminals on a particularly rough night,
but also when they have some important information
to share with one another. Usually, Bruce provides
Gordon with all the new information he finds --
though he kind of jumps the gun in the case of the
Riddler, even enacting an undercover scheme with
Selina at the club without telling Gordon, likely
because it's more personal than other cases.
Gordon in "The Batman" is not too different
from other iterations of the character
in that he values truth and justice over
violence and vengeance -- though there
does seem to be some leeway for him here,
as he looks the other way a bit, allowing Batman
to rough up some criminals here and there.
But all in all, it's Bruce's just nature that
convinces Gordon to keep working with him on
cases, and considering he literally brings the
vigilante to a crime scene, he clearly values
Bruce's detective abilities – unlike some people.
"How am I a part of this?"
"Oh, you're really not as
smart as I thought you were."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.